el Centro para el Control de Enfermedades (CDC) y Kaiser Permanente
descubrieron una situación de riesgo que era drásticamente responsable
de 7 de cada 10 causas principales de muerte en Estados Unidos.
En dosis altas, afecta al desarrollo del cerebro,
al sistema inmunológico, al sistema endocrino,
e incluso la forma de leer y replicarse de nuestro ADN.
Las personas expuestas a dosis muy altas
tienen 3 veces más probabilidades de morir
de enfermedades del corazón y cáncer de pulmón
y su esperanza de vida se reduce 20 años.
Y, sin embargo, los médicos hoy en día no están preparados
para su detección rutinaria o el tratamiento de la misma.
La situación a la que me refiero
no es un pesticida o un producto químico envasado
sino el trauma infantil.
Bueno, ¿de qué tipo de trauma estoy hablando?
No me refiero a no pasar un examen o perder un partido de baloncesto.
Estoy hablando de amenazas tan graves y prolongadas
que literalmente influyen en nuestro cuerpo y cambian nuestra fisiología:
cosas el abuso o el abandono,
o crecer con un padre que sufre una enfermedad mental
o lucha con la adicción a las drogas.
Bueno, durante mucho tiempo,
vi estas cosas como me enseñaron verlas:
como un problema social, hay que remitirlas a los servicios sociales
o como problema de salud mental,
hay que remitirla a los servicios de salud mental.
Pero luego sucedió algo que me hizo replantear todo mi enfoque.
Cuando terminé la residencia,
quería ir allí donde realmente me necesitaban,
donde podía marcar una diferencia.
Así que vine a trabajar al centro médico California Pacific
uno de los mejores hospitales privados en el norte de California,
y juntos abrimos una clínica en Bayview-Hunters Point,
una de los barrios más pobres y desfavorecidos de San Francisco.
Hasta entonces,
solo tenían un pediatra en todo el Bayview
que atendía a más de 10 000 niños.
Así que abrimos una práctica privada y ofrecimos cuidados de primera calidad,
incluso a aquellos que no podían pagar.
Era fantástico y nuestro objetivo eran las disparidades de salud típicas:
el acceso a la atención sanitaria, las tasas de inmunización,
tasas de hospitalización de asma, y tuvimos grandes resultados en todas.
Nos sentíamos muy orgullosos.
Pero luego empecé a notar una tendencia preocupante.
Me llegaban muchos niños con TDAH
o el Trastorno por Déficit de Atención e Hiperactividad,
pero cuando les hice todas las pruebas y analicé su historial clínico
descubrí que la mayoría de mis pacientes
no podían diagnosticarse con TDAH.
La mayoría de los niños que atendía habían pasado por traumas tan graves
que sentí que allí estaba pasando otra cosa.
De alguna manera, pasaba por alto algún detalle importante.
Antes de mi residencia, hice una maestría en salud pública,
y una de las cosas que se aprenden en la Escuela de Salud Pública
es que, si eres médico
y observas a 100 niños beber del mismo pozo
y 98 de ellos tienen diarrea,
uno puede prescribir sin dudar
varias dosis de antibióticos,
o puede detenerse a preguntar: "¿Qué demonios hay en ese pozo?"
Así que empecé a leer todo lo que pude
sobre cómo el estar expuesto a la adversidad
afecta el cerebro y el cuerpo en desarrollo de estos niños.
Entonces, un día, un colega entró en mi oficina
y dijo: "Dra. Burke, ¿ha visto esto?"
Y tenía en la mano una copia de un estudio de investigación
llamado "Estudio sobre las experiencias infantiles adversas".
Ese día cambió mi práctica clínica y, en última instancia, mi carrera.
El estudio sobre las experiencias infantiles adversas
es algo que todos necesitamos saber.
Realizado por el Dr. Vince Felitti del Kaiser, y el Dr. Bob Anda del CDC.
Juntos, investigaron 17 500 adultos
y sus historiales de exposición
acerca de las "experiencias adversas en la infancia", o EAI,
que incluye el abuso sexual, físico o emocional;
abandono físico o emocional;
enfermedad mental, drogodependencia o encarcelamiento de los padres;
separación o divorcio de los padres;
y violencia doméstica.
Para cada "sí", recibes un punto en la calificación de EAI.
Y luego correlacionaron
estas puntuaciones EAI con los resultados de su historial de salud.
Lo que encontraron fue sorprendente.
Dos cosas:
primero, las EAIs son muy comunes.
El 67 % de la población tenía al menos una EAI
y el 12,6 %, 1 de cada 8, tenía 4 o más EAIs.
La segunda cosa que encuentran
fue que había una relación dosis-respuesta
entre los EAIs y la salud:
más puntos EAI, peor salud.
Para una persona con una puntuación de EAI de 4 o más
el riesgo de enfermedad pulmonar obstructiva crónica
era 2,5 veces mayor que el de una persona con una puntuación de cero EAI.
Para la hepatitis también era 2,5 veces mayor.
Para la depresión, era 4,5 veces mayor.
Para suicidio, era 12 veces mayor.
Una persona con una puntuación de EAI de 7 o más
tenía 3 veces más probabilidades de morir de cáncer de pulmón,
y 3,5 veces mayor riesgo de isquemia cardíaca,
la causa principal de muerte en Estados Unidos.
Bueno, por supuesto que todo esto tiene sentido.
Algunos vieron estos datos y dijeron:
"Si tienes una infancia difícil, eres más propenso a fumar, beber,
y hacer todas estas cosas que arruinarán tu salud.
Esto no es ciencia. Es solo un mal comportamiento".
Pero ahí es exactamente donde interviene la ciencia.
Hoy en día entendemos más que nunca
que estar expuesto a la adversidad a una edad tan temprana
afecta el desarrollo del cerebro y el cuerpo de los niños.
Afecta áreas como el núcleo accumbens,
el centro del placer y recompensa en el cerebro,
el mismo que está involucrado en la drogodependencia.
Inhibe la corteza prefrontal
que interviene en el control de los impulsos y la función ejecutiva,
un área crucial para el aprendizaje.
Y, en una resonancia magnética,
se pueden ver cambios significativos en la amígdala,
el centro de respuesta al miedo del cerebro.
Por lo tanto, hay razones neurológicas reales
del porqué la gente expuesta a altas dosis de adversidad
es más propensa a involucrarse en comportamientos de alto riesgo,
y es importante saberlo.
Pero es que incluso si no adoptan un comportamientos de alto riesgo,
aún quedan más propensos a desarrollar enfermedades del corazón o cáncer.
La razón tiene que ver con el eje hipotalámico hipofisario adrenal,
el sistema corporal y cerebral de respuesta al estrés
que gobierna nuestra respuesta de lucha o huida.
¿Cómo funciona?
Bueno, imaginen que están caminando por un bosque y ven un oso.
Inmediatamente, el hipotálamo envía una señal a la glándula pituitaria,
que envía una señal a la glándula suprarrenal que dice:
"¡Suelte las hormonas del estrés! ¡Adrenalina! ¡Cortisol!"
El corazón empieza a latir con fuerza,
se dilatan las pupilas, se abren vías respiratorias
y están listos tanto para luchar con el oso o huir de él".
Y eso es maravilloso,
si se encuentran en un bosque y hay un oso.
(Risas)
Pero el problema es otro cuando el oso llega a casa todas las noches
y este sistema se activa repetidamente
y pasa de ser adaptable, y listo para salvarles la vida
a ser poco adaptativo o perjudicial para su salud.
Los niños son especialmente sensibles a esta activación repetitiva por el estrés,
porque su cerebro y el cuerpo todavía se están desarrollando.
Las dosis altas de la adversidad no solo afectan
a la estructura y a las funciones del cerebro,
sino también al sistema inmunológico en desarrollo,
el sistema hormonal en desarrollo,
e incluso la forma en que se lee y se transcribe nuestro ADN.
Para mí, esta información me hizo tirar por la borda lo que había aprendido,
porque cuando entendemos el mecanismo de una enfermedad,
cuando sabemos no solo qué vías están dañadas, sino también cómo,
nuestro trabajo como médicos, consiste en usar esta ciencia
para la prevención y el tratamiento.
Eso es lo que hacemos.
Así que en San Francisco, creamos el Centro para el Bienestar de la Juventud
para prevenir, diagnosticar y curar el impacto de las EAIs y estrés tóxico.
Empezamos solo con revisiones rutinarias en todos nuestros niños,
durante sus visitas de rutina,
porque sé que si mi paciente tiene una calificación de EAI de 4,
tiene 2,5 veces más probabilidades de desarrollar hepatitis o EPOC,
es 4,5 veces más propenso a tener depresión
y tiene 12 veces más probabilidades de quitarse la vida
que un paciente con EAI cero.
Y lo sé que cuando está en mi oficina.
Para los pacientes que dan positivo,
contamos con un equipo multidisciplinario
que trabaja para reducir la dosis de la adversidad
y para tratar los síntomas con las mejores técnicas,
incluyendo las visitas domiciliarias, coordinación de la atención,
atención psiquiátrica, nutrición,
intervenciones holísticas y, sí, medicación de ser necesario.
También instruir a los padres sobre el impacto de las EAIs y el estrés tóxico
de la misma forma en que lo haríamos para hablar de los enchufes
o sobre el envenenamiento por plomo,
y adaptamos el cuidado de nuestros asmáticos y diabéticos
para reconocer que quizá necesitan un tratamiento más agresivo
dados los cambios en sus sistemas endocrinos e inmunológicos.
Otra cosa que sucede cuando entendemos esta ciencia
es querer gritarlo a los 4 vientos
porque esto no es una cuestión que les pasa solo a los niños de Bayview.
Pensaba que en el momento que todos se enteraran
se organizarían pruebas de rutina, equipos multidisciplinarios de tratamiento
y habría una carrera para los protocolos más eficaces de tratamiento clínico.
Bueno. No fue lo que pasó.
Y fue una gran lección para mí.
Lo que pensé que iba a ser la mejor práctica clínica
hoy entiendo que es un cambio de actitud.
En palabras del Dr. Robert Block,
ex presidente de la Academia de Pediatría de EE.UU.:
"Las experiencias adversas en la infancia
son la mayor y principal amenaza no resuelta de la salud pública
a la cual se enfrenta hoy en día nuestra nación".
Y para mucha gente, es una perspectiva aterradora.
La escala y el alcance del problema parecen tan grandes que resulta abrumador
pensar cómo podemos abordarlo.
Pero para mí, en realidad, ahí radica la esperanza,
porque, si tenemos el marco adecuado,
si admitimos que esto es una crisis de salud pública,
entonces podemos empezar a usar
las herramientas adecuadas para generar soluciones.
Desde el tabaco al envenenamiento por plomo y el VIH/SIDA,
EE.UU. tienen en realidad una trayectoria bastante sólida
a la hora de abordar sus problemas de salud pública,
pero repetir la misma historia con éxito con las EAIs y el estrés tóxico
requerirá determinación y compromiso,
y cuando miro la reacción de nuestra nación hasta ahora
me pregunto:
"¿Por qué no hemos tomado esto más en serio?"
Al principio pensé que no damos importancia a la cuestión
porque no nos afecta a nosotros,
que era un problema de esos niños y los lugares de donde viven.
Lo cual ya es extraño, porque los datos no muestran eso.
El estudio original de EAIs fue realizado con una población
donde el 70 % eran blancos,
y 70 % tenían educación superior.
Y cuanto más hablaba con la gente,
más me daba cuenta de que, tal vez, lo había entendido todo al revés.
Si yo preguntara cuántas personas en esta sala
se criaron en una familia donde alguien tenía una enfermedad mental,
apuesta que algunos levantarían la mano.
Y si preguntara cuántos tuvieron un padre que bebía también
o que creía que si no pegaba al niño lo echaba a perder
apostaría que unos cuantos más levantarían la mano.
Incluso en esta sala, este problema afecta a muchos de nosotros,
y empiezo a creer que no le damos importancia a este tema
porque se aplica a todos nosotros.
Tal vez es más fácil ver el problema en otros sitios,
porque no hay que fijarse en ello.
Preferimos permanecer enfermos.
Afortunadamente, los avances científicos y la verdad, la realidad económica
hacen que esta opción sea menos viable cada día.
La ciencia es clara:
las adversidades de la infancia afectan drásticamente la salud toda la vida.
Hoy en día, estamos empezando a entender cómo detener la progresión
de la adversidad temprana a la enfermedad y a la muerte prematura,
y, en 30 años,
el niño con una alta puntuación de EAI,
cuyos síntomas en el comportamiento pasan desapercibidas,
cuyo control del asma no está correlacionada
y que acaba desarrollando hipertensión
alguna enfermedad cardíaca o el cáncer a una edad temprana
será tan inusual
como alguien una tasa de mortalidad para el VIH/SIDA de 6 meses.
La gente al ver estos casos dirá: "¿Qué diablos pasó?"
Esto es tratable.
Se puede luchar contra eso.
Lo más importante que necesitamos hoy
es el valor para enfrentar este problema
y admitir que existe y que nos afecta a todos.
Creo que nosotros mismos somos el cambio.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)